わっしょい
おし
!#$*%+`%=$"=#"!?<}?
フアフア
ヒェーハーハーハーハ―
終わり
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
聞いて驚け！
天下の、ダイドーさんとの動画です
いやぁ、テンション高まるよ
何度お世話になったことか
ダイドーさんのジュースには
というわけで、今回はこちら
もう、たぶん知ってる人も多いと思います
中にゼリーが入ってて
10回以上振ってから飲むと
あ～～～～～
飲みてぇー！
飲みたい、飲みたい、飲みたいけど...
禁止中です
僕はちょっと飲めないんですけども
もう、この美味しさは知っております
そう、僕は飲みたいけど飲めない
僕はこの思いをどうすればいいのか
そこで僕は閃いた
いま、ここ後輩の「まさき」の家にいるんですけども
ソーダ―ゼリーを飲めない僕の怒りを
彼に全部ぶつけてみようと思います
名付けて！
というドッキリをやってみようと思います
まあ、震えるパターンとしては2パターンあるでしょう
の2パターンがあると思います
いま、まさきちょっと出かけてて
外にいるんですけども
飲みたい
僕も、ダイドーさんの自販機信者なんで
2つの食感ソーダゼリーか
もう一つ
ミスティオのクリスタルレモンスカッシュの2択のどっちかを
選びます、いつも
もう、僕はこの二択です
ってくらい好きなんですよ！！
でも、飲めない！(怒)
アォーー！
段ボール一つに24缶入ってます
それがいま22箱あるので
500個以上置いてあります
2つの食感ソーダゼリー500個で作られた壁を見て
何を感じて、どう表情で表して、震えるか？
振って飲むんですよ
ふるふる
ふるふるしたいよ！
飲みたいよ！羨ましいよ！
はい、というわけで早速
2つの食感ソーダゼリーを500個並べていきましょう
おっ
その前に
動画の最後にプレゼント企画があるので是非最後まで見てください
お得だぜ！
では行こう！
では、ちょっと本気で並べます
500個ってさ、結構やばくない？
あー、やべーかもやべーかもやべーかもやべーかも
いやぁー、だめかも
すいません、ちょっと高くしすぎるとやっぱり
不安定になって倒れちゃうんで
壁に、壁にそらせてやりましょう
ちょっとチェンジ、壁にそらせてやります
よし
はいっ、できました
はっはっはっはっはっ
いやぁー、もう感動ものですな
ここまで来ると俺もやった甲斐があったよ
やばい、もうすぐ帰ってくる
もうすぐたぶん帰ってくると思います
さあ、果たしてターゲットは
この500個の振って飲むソーダゼリーを見て
彼自身も震えるのかどうか
そこが、今回のポイントでございます
俺ね、俺これね、あのさ普通にね予想だと喜ぶと思うんすよ
やったー、ありがとうみたいなさー
というわけで、たぶんもうすぐ来るので
ちょっと、待ってみましょう
ではターゲットを待ちましょう
もうもうもうもう来ます、もう来ます
もうもう来ます、もう来ます
はじめ）おかえりーっす！
まさき）えっ、何？
まさき）だってww
おかしくない？www
おかしくない？ww
おかしくない？w
まさき）壁紙変わってない？
はじめ）アーハーハーハーハーハーハーww
まさき）ねぇっ、ほらこっちにもぉ
はじめ）どう、どう？
まさき）どう？って...
まさき）いやぁー、よくやったね
はじめ）あんまり震えませんでした
はじめ）はい、というわけで こちらの
２つの食感ソーダゼリー➡︎
と、なっております
はじめ）10回以上振って飲むんですけども
降る回数によってね、すごい食感とかが変わるんです
10回、20回、30回で振るから
違いが分かったらいいっすね
はじめ）じゃあとりあえず10回
1、2、3、4、5、6、7、8、9、10
まず10回振ったのを飲んでもらいましょう
まさき）じゃあいただきまーす
はじめ）はーい
まさき）うん、美味しい、なんか柔らかい、ゼリーが
10回振るとまだゼリー感はある？
「ある、ある、ナタデココもあるし、」
ほぉー
シュワシュワしてる、おいしいね、これ
へぇ～（おれもほしい）
では次、20回行きましょう
はい、20回
いただきま～す
どうすか
さっきより細かくなってるんで、
一気に口の中にたくさんゼリーが入ってくる感じ
へぇ～
おいしいよ
は～ん（怒）
じゃあ次、30回飲んでもらいましょう
はい
30回まで行くとたぶんもうねぇ、
さらっとなってくる気がする
味はどうでしゅかぁ
30回降ると、結構ナチュラルに飲める
すぅ～っとはいってくるってこと？
うん。
ほ～
これは個人的になんですけど、10回が好きなんすよ
ちょっと吸って頑張って入ってくるくらいの
振った回数によっていろんな味の楽しみ方ができる
2つの食感ソーダゼリーでございます
っていうわけで、
僕が甘いものを食べれた時期ではめちゃくちゃ飲んでいたソーダゼリー
是非皆さんも飲んでみてください
ここでですね
この2つの食感ソーダゼリーが今、キャンペーンをやっておりまして
ちょっとそちらの話をしようと思います
2つの食感ソーダゼリー写真ツイートキャンペーン
いや～、これ本当に簡単で誰でも応募できるというものなんですけれども
ツイッターを使います
本数によってプレゼントが変わってくると、
まさき） ほー
ソーダゼリー一本持ってツイートすると、こちら！
こちらのスマホにつける用のレンズ、「セルカレンズ」がプレゼントされます
こちら5本を持って写真を撮ってツイートすると、
こちらの超大容量モバイルバッテリーがプレゼントされます
はい、というわけで
10本持った写真をツイートすると、
マジでほしいやつだね
はい、こちらのヘッドホンがプレゼントされます
10本持つって結構、結構ね、結構あれなんですけど、なんか面白い感じになってしまうと思うんですけど、
10本持ってツイート
するとこちらのヘッドホンがプレゼント対象になります
聞かないと良さは分かりませんから
どう？
音質いい？
とても良いでございます
こちらのキャンペーン応募期間がありまして、
7月11日の午前10時までとなっております
それまでに皆さん写真を撮って是非ツイートしてみてください
1回ちょっとやってみよう
（カシャ）
あ～、これはもういきますね～完全に
はい、というわけでこんな感じのツイートをすると
応募範囲になっております
これさ、バカ丸出しじゃん（笑）
上限が10本になっておりますのでこういう感じで撮っても
応募は10本のプレゼント対象となっております
はい、というわけでこちらの
2つの食感ソーダゼリーは全国のダイドー自販機で販売しております
是非皆さん買って応募してみてください！
じゃあな！
待って、賞味期限いつ？
あっ！2017年！間に合う、